[Music]
welcome back
an ohio man admits he and his family
slaughtered eight members of another
family
law and crimes angenet levy explains how
the guilty play
could tear apart the wagner family's
loyalty to one another
prosecutors have described the wagner
family as cult-like
but that could be changing as they sit
in jail awaiting trial
for the rodent and gilly murders
for the first time since his younger
brother jake confessed to investigators
george wagner appeared in court in what
was supposed to be a hearing to argue
motions
but jake wagner's guilty plea has
changed things
i think everybody's agreed that given
recent events
that everybody needs to step back and
reassess last week on the fifth
anniversary of the murders
jake wagner pleaded guilty to a laundry
list of charges
including conspiracy aggravated murder
and unlawful sexual contact with a minor
for his relationship with hannah may
rhoden the mother of his child
prosecutors say wagner admitted that
custody of that child was the motive for
the murders
i agree to what the state's provided
and i'm deeply in varied sorry jake said
his family planned and carried out the
murders as most of the victims slept
the guilty plea represents a massive
split among the wagner family members
who had presented a united front for the
last five years
prosecutors wrote that the wagners
functioned as a unit
at all times residing together in a very
insular manner
holding family meetings and voting on
all affairs
including when it came to children and
wives and sharing financial resources
and accounts
it's not clear what george wagner will
do after learning more about what his
brother told investigators
and he said nothing as he left court
hi george do you have anything to say
wagner remains in jail where his
attorneys have said in the past he sits
in his cell
and reads the bible he'll be back in
court in june
for law and crime daily i'm anginette
levy
thanks angenet let's bring in imran and
terry one last time to discuss
imran jake wagner's guilty plea has to
be throwing in somewhat of a monkey
wrench for the other defendants
what do you think the attorneys for the
others are saying to their clients right
now
well i would be very concerned about the
information that was given to law
enforcement and to prosecutors
in advance of this plea deal and how
it's going to actually affect
each of those other defendants because
it may implicate them
it may make them criminally culpable and
i think that their defense is going to
be all the more complicated brian
after this development all right now
terry i agree with enron it's going to
get a lot more complicated but
it seems the death penalty is officially
off the table but do you expect pleas or
trials
after this or could maybe another family
member
uh say that the others weren't more
involved than them
you know what brian anything is possible
this is what i'm hoping i am hoping that
we see
trials and that the prosecution doesn't
enter
into a plea agreement with any of the
other relatives because
anything less than a life sentence is
not going to be enough and we know that
it's a life sentence because the plea
deal that was taken
made sure that each of them got life
sentences and that there was no death
penalty
for any of them so as far as i'm
concerned the heinous nature of this
crime makes it so that they should serve
as long
as possible and unless they have
something that is additional or
corroborating
i don't think they need to make any
deals at all
imran maybe just my defense attorney
mindset is spinning here if i'm
representing another wagner
i may make the argument uh whether true
or not we gotta see how the facts lay
jake wagner was coerced he's the younger
brother he's trying to help the family
maybe what he's saying is not as true
as it is maybe he's just trying to be a
good kid and save the family could that
be an argument for the other
wagners to save their case it could be
o'brien but it also could be the
argument that he's giving information to
save himself
and whatever deal he may have worked out
with the prosecutors i guess we're gonna
have to wait and see
exactly thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss
justice in america
you